-Michael, I want
to keep the interview going,
but I thought we'd make the
conversation a little bit more
interesting with a game
we call "Word Sneak."
Here we go.
-♪ Word Sneak, Word Sneak ♪
-Here's how it works.
We each have cards with
random words written on them,
and our goal is to work these
words into the conversation
as casually and seamlessly
as possible.
Make sense?
-Got it. Okay, okay, okay.
-All right, so, now,
you look at your top card.
I'll look at mine.
You start it off
and let the Word Sneak begin.
Michael, any plans
for the summer?
-Uh, the summer? Yeah.
You know,
I love getting outdoors.
You've been to Venice Beach?
You know, they have the bicycles
and, like, the Rollerblades.
-Oh, yeah. I love Venice Beach.
-[ Bell dings ]
-You know, outside -- You just
kind of like -- you just --
-Yeah, and do you go right home
when you go from the beach?
You go right into your house?
-Uh, no, no.
Actually, you know,
I need to drive,
but sometimes, like,
the 405 is so packed.
You know, I mean,
there's like boats, tugboats,
and things like that.
I just kind of try to --
-[ Bell dings ]
-You snuck in your word already.
I was just saying,
if you go to your house,
there's probably sand
all over the place,
so you got to get a Roomba
to clean it up.
-[ Bell dings ]
-But it's no big deal.
-Oh, okay.
-But, I mean, that's good.
So you do that. Then --
And then you go on the 405.
You know what I like to do
when I used to drive?
I used to --
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-Used to get a little nervous.
Get a little nervous
before I'd drive, so...
-Really?
-Yeah, but my grandpa
told me a little trick.
Throw down a couple of
appletinis before you --
-[ Bell dings ]
-Really?
-Make sure you don't drive
too fast, of course, yeah.
-See, that's crazy
that he told you the appletinis.
For me, you know, I'm a eater.
You know, I eat, so --
What really, like, settles
my stomach and my nerves
when I do drive is --
You know, it's crazy.
Sometimes refried beans.
And, like, you know --
[ Bell dings ]
-Wow. Refried beans is what
calms your nerves down?
-Yeah. You know, with nachos.
You know what I'm saying?
I like nachos.
Sometimes you got to put
the layer of refried beans.
-I can't eat that stuff.
I can't eat that stuff
'cause I blow up
like a medium-sized ostrich.
-[ Bell dings ]
-People are like --
-Really?
-Yeah.
Medium --
-Okay.
-You know, so I can't do
that type of stuff anymore.
-And then, you know, if you blow
up like a medium-sized ostrich,
you know,
the nachos that I usually --
You know, sometimes you might
chew on something crazy
and, you know --
-I guess. I guess.
-The teeth.
You know what I'm saying?
Like, sometimes your tooth's
all -- You're crazy.
Like, my dentist actually
stopped seeing me,
and I had to go see
John Cena's dentist.
[ Bell dings ]
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, I had to go
see him one time.
-Wow.
-He took me in last-minute.
It was great. It was great.
It was great.
-John Cena's dentist?
-Yeah.
-Yeah, and that's interesting
'cause he --
The dentist actually says,
"You can't see me,"
as he's operating on you.
-[ Laughs ]
I see what you did.
-I know that dentist,
'cause I went to this weird
party a couple years ago,
and I ended up in a hot tub
with John Cena's dentist --
was in there.
-Okay.
-Crazy.
A lot of people in there.
Cindy Adams was in there.
Biv from Bell Biv Devoe
was in there.
-Hmm.
Could've been Bell.
I think it was Biv, though.
Biv was there.
-Okay, okay.
-This dude who played bass for
one of Brian McKnight's tours.
-Okay.
-Uh, uh, uh, the dude that --
who drew Scooter --
he did the voice of Scooter
from "Muppet Babies."
He was in there.
Just a bunch -- The kid from
"Jerry Maguire" was in there.
-Wait. How big was --
-[ Bell dings ]
-Really?
-Yeah, it was just --
I had to get
the hell out of there.
-I mean, what kind of --
That's a big hot tub.
-It was a small pool.
It was a small pool.
-Small pool.
-But all those people in there
at once made it hot, you know?
-Gotcha.
-Yeah, heated it right up.
-Yes, yes, yes. Yes.
-Yeah. You ever been to, like,
a crazy party or something?
-Yeah. You know what?
I'm more of a --
I'm a homebody, you know?
-Yeah.
-And I --
Sometimes I pick up hobbies.
You know, like,
I don't know, guitar or --
You know,
tattooing was something
that I was interested in
at one point.
-Wow.
That's an interesting hobby.
-Sometimes I do random
piercings, you know,
lip piercings
and stuff like that.
If you wanted it, I could,
like, give you a lip ring.
You know, I could do that.
-[ Bell dings ]
-You could.
-If you were into it.
-[As Elmer Fudd] I'm weally,
weally scared of that.
[ Laughter ]
I'm weall-- I'm --
That's scare-wee.
Weally scare-wee.
-That sounds like --
What is that?
Was that --
That sounds like Bugs Bunny.
-Oh, you wascally wabbit.
[ Bell dings ]
[ Laughter ]
[Normal voice] That's my man.
He set me up.
Michael B. Jordan!
That's my man right there!
His new movie,
"Without Remorse,"
is available tomorrow
on Amazon Prime Video.